hello reject nation Greg Alva theer
Cassidy Letterman has returned get a
channel we have to go to archery so I
only have time to fill in one video
before she disappears for a month but
let me squeeze one in really quick
followed her on social media links in
description but hey you know what I
found out after he did the videos with
us she's an entourage I love that he
didn't know this I had no idea all the
comments came in weird yeah we got when
you don't know we call it yeah pay
attention I was some people thing right
totally yeah validation with other
people Gallagher actually we're gonna
watch us by the video five youtubers who
mysteriously disappear from YouTube and
Cassidy watches so much YouTube is
ridiculous how are you know any of these
yeah I might not have a them either well
let's uh let's find out good channel top
five items YouTube has been around since
2005 so it's no secret that in those 12
years its bore witness to the
unexplained disappearances of some of
its creators number five grade eight
under a oh this [ __ ] I know I wouldn't
I said I went on his videos became much
more controversial and what are they
considered Alinea failures
and over the last three months great as
I floated no content other than a
one-minute clip maybe explaining that he
has a helped condition so this all while
it you would upload a follow-up video
within a couple days but that video
never came it's no secret that an absent
such as this can completely ruin a
channel and great has lost a fair amount
of subscribers during this time greats
channel had been declining for months
leading up to that but why well a lot of
people are choosing to special
Internet's of the elastic chain of all
time that going great first started many
of its videos revolved around everyday
activities or social constructs that
you're attending a great story I don't
stone this content extremely relatable
covering this channel to grow at an
alarming rate
whether that's time I aren't telling
videos because I went to grammar
yup most notably youtube drama well
great YouTube drama videos did gain
quite a bit of popularity
it was extremely short-lived and many of
his original viewers felt betrayed by
this sudden change result great loss of
millions original fame while his new
fans proved to be far less dedicated
resulting this channels imminent clock
because of this some believe that his
channel simply wasn't doing well enough
to remain profitable causing him to
pursue other endeavors and that
supposedly his health problems were
simply a cover-up number 5 vodka exact
rate survey by doin a thousand jobs at
the time of recorded losses pranks used
to bring in 118 range the videos to know
that he someone has disappeared from the
platform for just over two years with
seemingly no explanation a very long he
has returned in recent months somewhat
claimed he was hired at a tree-cutting
service but this is no baking firm
recently attend a yoga class ruins at
stop signs that he deemed unnecessary it
was later arrested for this and charged
with third degree felony for grand theft
well later we'll ask a video explaining
the situation pleading with the
subscribers to donate to his man roster
scratches chair comedy courage and
creativity saying Ross can't help but
push the limits as he struggles to find
his place in society summarizing his
videos as entertainment drinks and
stunts this statement makes it seem that
he realizes his videos are technically
pranks but more about doing stupid
things they ultimately ended with him in
jail in this video in which he was
removing stop signs he and his friends
laugh as cars go through the
intersection without stopping is that
pretty low in cinema
well a lot of 13s crime in a video that
he faces up to five years in prison
we blunt yes should glad that his
channel wasn't be activated by YouTube
as this video goes directly against
YouTube's Terms of Service prohibiting
videos that promote reckless and danger
Oh many have compared Ross's video with
Sam peppers Craven oh one time leaving
YouTube all me what is it insane baby I
put a note on that kidnapped or
remarried or one of them mutual
acquaintances
a practice in Iran is supposed to be
good-natured and we revealed everybody
much
and no one has been put in any danger
but Rosses videos did not fit this
description like I wanna machetes drop
from millions in their tens of thousands
causing a showdown completely Dorner
number three though he refers Brendan
Dillon Asher aged 31 in crowd youtuber
uploading videos to YouTube personality
Bachelor verse he also in physics
centric voice in scripted minecraft
series the web hobo which is gained in
hundreds thousands of subscribe latin is
brandon has been involved in multiple
sexual misconduct charges twice
involving mine once he was arrested for
having inappropriate online chat
boundary girl
wha-ha-ha drove our channel keemstar
claims that Brenda had also been charged
for sexual assault of another young girl
because of team starts track record this
is widely believed for novels because of
King stars remarks Brandon received an
unprecedented amount of hate as well as
death threats this cause brain is a
breakdown on camera on multiple
occasions which almost home to fueled
fire in October of 2015
Braman expressed his remaining fans that
he was severely depressed and suicidal
adding that he was being called a
pedophile and a rapist on a date one day
oh hey guys it's me alright sorry
I'm done alright I'm so [ __ ] tired of
we have a place fine we don't want
absolutely freakin man um I didn't
expected freaking get this big and I
didn't expect like my past today to get
almost and came sonic because Billy I
just wanted to make a youtube channel
sorry
absolutely no one I'm not a pedophile
when you win okay oh oh
[Music]
my daughter Suman this Britain's leader
in water what about the video nawaz's of
Swing Rohan that I have so many question
Waseem to get to Kingston following this
nothing which has heard from brandy
again then a short time later his videos
were all Gabrus all in the other file
was he a rapist bill things I don't know
if it was a cheese but I'll be he was
convicted I mean I think you're accused
that's good enough the likelihood is
like why is someone accusing you of that
like I believe the victims along with I
would well I'm stuck oh boy
that was uncomfortable Brandon was later
involved in a feud involving fellow
youtuber VP is here though this was
saddled relatively quickly after which
you're teamed up to file a defamation
lawsuit against Kingston following this
nothing which was heard from Brandon
ginger all the traitor had one area
remains your can we move from this
channel and its channel art was changed
to black as of May of 2017
Brandon's channel remains empty and all
of the social media has been private
adore blacked out as well it's unknown
what exactly is going on with bash
reverse but it's safe to assume that the
hate between fellow YouTube creators
caused him to call it quits at least for
now
little is too scarce John scarce
interview super reports on YouTube news
and drama he was at one point the
largest growing news reporting General
on YouTube it's just over 2.8 million
subscriber Wow Skinner started its
channel in early 2012 it was originally
famous within the call of duty community
horse trick shot videos but in early
2013 scarce begin creating news
commentaries getting a large fanbase
fairly quickly then after a shoutout
from grade 8 under ain't early 2016
scarcest popularity reached an all-time
high in March of 2016 which is around
the beginning of the YouTube Las Vegas
and keemstar
despite being rivals collaborated in
effort surged advertisers to return to
the platform following a series of
events involving certain ads being
played alongside external jewish
corporation the ghoul can cook cooler
for not going
as though before the video could be
posted coca-cola pulled their ads as
well scarcest channel continued on
without much interruption to the
following year however on May 24 playing
a semi killing polyols when a Tata crew
seated those homeless Casey nice that
banned from flying Gerald in New York
City daddy-o 5 back here suddenly
stopped uploading going silent on all
social platforms his whereabouts are
currently unknown
we just sparked many jokes in the
comment section of the affirmation video
such as its sudden death or a
relationship with a psycho girlfriend in
all seriousness though it's very likely
that scare simply left the platform
because it was no longer profitable he's
expressed his dissatisfaction with
YouTube's ad revenue multiple times in
the past even threatening to leave
YouTube at one point he's also come
under fire in the past for double up
early with many of his fans claiming
that he was only doing this for the ad
revenue I just quality of content seem
to drastically lower during these times
let's keep our fingers crossed and hopes
that YouTube will continue to see
advertisers returning in the future but
for now a scarce and future as well as
YouTube's future as a whole seems bleak
number one my role Kaos is an English
actor rapper gamer and internet
personality he's the most well known
member of the popular gaming group Simon
and originally made mostly gaming
related videos so am I on - Jenna's past
the back where he frequently plays video
games with celebrities ksi has not
uploaded videos to any of his channels
since February of 2017
it has also blacked out most of his
profile pictures and banners across all
of his YouTube and social media accounts
he also took down previous videos to
have over two billion views involves
Instagram post except for one ksi
followed this with a series of tweets
which has now been deleted in which he
explained that he had come to dislike
the fame and special privileges that
came with being what he called a
celebrity he also stated that he wants
to become a more normal person he also
tweeted quote by Charles Darwin that
says we stopped looking for monsters
under our bed when we realized they were
inside us in an interview with drum
alerts keemstar ksi revealed that he did
all of this we could evaluate himself as
a person and stated that he doesn't care
about that
Clemson's not imprecise has been
completely inactive on all of the social
media until we upload a photo on
Instagram on the 6th of May
growth he has since been featured in
other side ones videos and took part the
2017 charity football match on the 23rd
of June 2017 ksi posted a new video
entitled it's been a while
responding the hum nail reading YouTube
for Android content which seems to be
sending mixed signals
as mentioned previously ksi stated he
left YouTube and social media to
reevaluate himself and become a better
person
however the contents of her stomach
accompanied by the timing of his
departure and return or meeting many
fans to believe that he actually left
the platform because of that pocalypse
issue contradicting his remarks
mentioned that he doesn't care about the
money
ksi is expected to release a new content
on June 30th 2017 ok didn't so much
stops doing if you want your speaking
over saving the money one well honey I
subscribe to our channel for all of our
future videos no the money hasn't been
resolved casting ok money because I
don't even know what this a sure you
don't follow any of this stuff
several months ago YouTube changed your
algorithm on how videos get promoted and
then and how videos get seen and what
kind of a lot of things they change in
the search engine and right away videos
a lot of channels sort of complaints
about the algorithm change and including
this one but I go yeah this channel that
it dip in our channel and I knew all I
know plenty of youtubers plenty of like
big youtubers who were affected about
just the algorithm change their view
start going down they start losing
subscribers because people sort of
getting an unsubscribe
wait ok a magically unsubscribe daily
didn't because YouTube was trying to
filter out people who are like inactive
accounts or accounts that they don't
really use but then there were people
and we've I've gotten many comments even
to this day I still get comments of like
you to keep them subscribing me for some
reason and so he is happening so yeah
our our channel numbers dipped a lot and
then a few months ago I watched like two
hours of video worth on it so I can't
explain it I don't my god but I users
been able to go do this thing called an
ad pocalypse
and you should type in hashtag
apocalypse on Twitter and people you'll
see like plenty of youtubers are still
complaining about a tease what happened
was a lot of [ __ ] YouTube lost about 750
million dollars in
Jim ad revenue and and then they start
filtering all their content out like for
example a video like this of us just
discussing a top of a numb but it will
probably do a lot better than the
Buchanan probably has now suppose you do
but because it feels a darker content
it's probably not going to perform its
own even top five unknowns videos I
would have dipped as well because
they're becoming like really corporate
that it's like sixty television again
they're becoming very corporate about it
where they're trying to tend more to
videos that are extremely
family-friendly content so I get that's
what that ksi youtuber was kind of
mocking there yeah so depending Academy
yeah the income from a lot of youtubers
have dipped anywhere from like fifty to
eighty percent
yeah tough I barely make revenue because
it's much overly when well the ad pas
gross has been going on for a few couple
months now to three months and it's
still going on no they should still be
as fairly new but a lot of people have
been leaving YouTube what I've learned
yeah I'm not known for VidCon to never
freak out like I didn't go to big on
community and I'm like VidCon in general
even if ads we're going great I want to
go to Big Boi convict maybe some segment
people talked about it but there's a lot
of people who are using other platforms
now to try to supplement some people are
go to like twitch now like some people
do like other live streaming services do
you have patreon we have a patreon now
are you using the [ __ ] name I'm weird
but like it's such a genius idea like
why did they why are they changing it
like what was the point of that is
education I don't know why the algorithm
change occurred the ad pocalypse
occurred because a few videos were found
to be advertising on content that was
perceived as racist and more violent and
so companies were like this isn't right
one that make sense
it makes sense in some fashion but then
if my use the F word or a sex joke or
even talk about sex you used to be able
to average out every thousand views
equated went from $1 to $3 a video not
long ago there's a video we got passed
like a hundred thousand beats feed and
the video probably heard about 20 25
yeah and it still happens so even so
it's like you can't be fooled by numbers
is there some channels you still have
number videos that probably do really
well in views but that doesn't mean that
they're still profiting with easy so a
lot of people have been leaving YouTube
or doing less videos linked to but how
do they know if you talked about sides
of the video
there's some one screening your videos
someone screen all the crownless videos
they go up on YouTube it mainly look at
thumbnail title and description the
avatar some type of dark content at all
perceived or anything inappropriate
whatsoever no echo no intent for the ad
revenues yes pretty bad we tested it out
for a while John and I we we were for
like a week we were like you know what
let's what's intentionally not cuss or
make a sex joke and let's see if it
changes it now they may know differently
Sara why did this report it lets us keep
doing artists red words dumb jokes yeah
man everything on that Nikki it makes no
difference it doesn't it's like
sometimes the video does well sometimes
it doesn't but yeah a lot of changes
have been happening I still just like
making videos I'm still here yeah I mean
like I've gone over like grade a ton
during the beginning okay who was that
idea it was a guy who loved to attack
other channels or talk about problems
with the world Nina and there was a time
where he was attacking like I wasn't one
of the main targets I was mentioned a
couple times
really I had other friends who were
really involved in it Tyrone Magna sees
a big reaction channel and he had like a
video segment series like why reaction
channels are [ __ ] and I'll know that
like the way after he did his video like
we lost subs we had we had a lot of
people defend us because we did we were
different in a lot of ways from other
reaction channels like we'd like to go
into like a lot of discussion there's a
lot of reaction channels I'm not going
to say who's specifically but there
there are other edge channels are just
reacting then say subscribe yeah but we
like to kind of give a lot of
conversation and edit the discussion
parts of these you know yes and top five
unknowns they're okay with us doing
reactions to their videos so I'm like
alright that's cool and sometimes
youtubers aren't okay if you react to
their video really mm-hmm that's bizarre
but I didn't know about greedy hundred I
haven't centigrade
in like over years I had no idea that it
disappeared all that well they made us
only there's like a conspiracy like I
measure them be like an animal in common
that yeah I'm like boo Quiles but they
said he said he had some health issue or
then his channel was already declining
and I didn't know anything like that and
as much as I was joking around saying
like [ __ ] and all that I let it all go
Mike whatever is like I got through
something like I don't need to try to
make this guy happy I don't know a lot
of a sudden the person is yeah it's like
some people just don't like you and you
deal with it but nobody passed what he
did on the channel like poke people yeah
that's his main thing with attacking
people and apparently it did really like
he went to a million subs pretty fast I
don't know what happened it was channel
but I hope he's alright because I don't
I really don't hate the guy I mean there
was a time where yeah I [ __ ] hated
the guy but there really did you men
talk like in common like how did you
ever Twitter there was one time we were
like going back and forth and I didn't
like how he was attacking a friend of
mine I hated that and I could kind of
got involved in it and because I was
being put in the same category as a lot
of a lot of things he was talking about
but that was a long time ago so really I
did not like him but then after a while
it just Donnelly I'm like but that's
just what this guy does it's what his
channel is only had taken to a personal
anymore oh no I really hope he's
actually alright well I think I hate his
rear do like have some serious health
condition that causes him to stop making
videos of anime a lot of people really
did like it but ha to use still for
thinking you could use this if you come
back and want to attack me use this way
yeah yeah you should go ahead and find
does it feel do you go for a generated I
don't know who this channel was the guy
didn't Minecraft videos I once did a
video I really regret that I've had to
work my ass off to take down and get
people to not reupload it where I was
crying about some personal life [ __ ] all
the video was was me crying that's when
I told people my name is not Ryan Wright
it's Greg it was a bad day for me yeah
and uh because I was like I shouldn't
have put it I sure enough put up this
video I guess after that day I know
well I did take it down but then other
people downloaded it and re-uploaded it
and and it's been like well over a year
since that video went out but the quiz
this guy did like screaming at me oh
yeah a living [ __ ] oh my god I'm so
unnecessary it's like I don't know I
don't know I don't know enough about the
situations I don't really want to make
any judgment call but I normally did to
feel like if you're called about foul
that's coming from somewhere yeah well I
think you're kind of fun
Dannan now let me just coming back
somewhere be at my odds I've labeled you
as a pedophile I don't believe all that
normally don't you think of it I don't
know maybe not I don't know call me
about that now study about it like I
don't know anyone in my world but anyone
has ever said oh I think he's a
pedophile I'm gonna mean glad you don't
know any further bottom I give you new
people and you know people just worry
about that but like that's a weird thing
to lie about learn science
oh yeah I don't know where he's coming
well here's the thing though is like it
could have just been a gym because the
guy we need the way he talks and stuff
when it's once I heard the kinds of kids
being a pedophile my instant Joker
reaction was about totally how it sounds
mean is that yeah bloody a lot of
details behind it I don't I mean even if
it was true I feel weird saying it I
kind of felt a little sorry for him just
to like freak out like that and then
disappear this reminds me of Black
Mirror don't know why oh yeah I do not
owe greater technology baby no social
interaction don't because like that
situation a guy with a gun the knife um
Shekhar's for that okay the young
cabling our age oh my god like the third
season oh yeah yeah oh my god I just
think that thing and that's I think why
I feel so strongly about it because I
don't I'm Ruben anything but basically
like you feel for the guy the whole time
you're like oh this poor kids poor kid
then the one
don't like I just feel like if he is a
pedophile I don't know much remorse for
him because that's really really [ __ ]
up what if he isn't oh yeah like I need
to know more about the situation and I
feel a lot informed yeah mad about it
I could see it might be like a cheap a
bigger channel because I mean I know I
have friends who are like trying other
things now because YouTube is not
recovered from the apocalypse much some
people are not as affected by others
this channel has definitely been right
when these changes included everything
just dip suddenly like here everything
it wasn't like oh we were doing
something and then the channel just went
down in quality it was like something
just changed where you just see the
numbers you're like why did everything
so when we did it and then you started
noticing all occur on the platform and
on top of that to YouTube is a drama
fear age not just like comments are just
a Wurmple look like black darkness like
oh my god it's so scary and me and yeah
I deal with that dealing with hate is
not easy as much as people tell you you
know if you do YouTube and you start
getting some success you will get hate I
don't think anything truly prepares you
for it I don't think anything will can
truly prepare you for the amount of
hatred that can be out there because
I've had to I've had periods where
there's a lot of hate coming my way and
every day is a hate comment now I'm a
little bit more and different well you
don't have to be you have helping your
skin it's hard it's one thing to
conceptualize the hate like it'll haters
back off what's another to have someone
attack you for the way you look the way
you talk the way you sound of knowing it
is a personal attack on you yeah instead
of just hate the first attacks that are
harder yeah and I feel like that is what
a lot of the comments are obviously very
personal I get under your skin like the
one insecurity you might have they're
like yeah yeah yeah like the emaki have
been like great your penis is too big we
can see it keep getting close about how
big my penis is and I just need it a lot
until you to stop you know it's like I
know it's a condition I want to get
shrunk you hear that guys it's a good
different I can say alright thank you
Cassie is always looking I'm like
self-judgment what Wow
after I'm done we're going by Alvin
Toffler do it harder than me are you
Kevin maybe not you're over me
how are you squeaky or rearrange our
cameras or daggers actually no
joon-young in yes I said young and I'm
sorry sir cute okay yeah you're a little
evil anyway are you are ya
Mike I was older than you you ain't no
too young in call me old me other day
blues one thing I was like well yeah
right oh they're probably gonna watch
those my good name one one the video
games or one well 3 a.m. is reppin
supreme youtubers who disappeared I hope
you guys are all healthy and safe and
you're not something like you might be
in jail so I'm you're finding yourself I
get it if you have to disappear for a
while I mean there are times where I
once went through a whole month of not
reading comments good yeah I mean my
whole channels based off requests so I
had to like eventually start any comment
again don't reason so so you never know
what comments are coming in but yeah
there is a time where it's like a solid
month of like I'm not going to read any
comments it's like of a popular movie
trailer drops I'll know I'm probably
getting comments to check it out but
there's a month I just didn't read
comments because after a while because
even if it's not hate I didn't like the
feeling of getting my validation off of
people loving me so I don't I didn't
want to get my definition off of people
hating me or people loving me so now
it's like I'll take like 10 to 20
minutes a day to just look through the
comments to see what's being requested
and sometimes I replied at the positive
comments but yeah I mean it's cool it's
very weird think that it is it's fake
like they you know I don't want to say
fake because it isn't such a real thing
like you know you have this on your
phone your computer or wherever you
already feel very intimate very intim
with it and it's not like we're being
thing we're very much who we are
represented creating something that's so
true and authentic real but then when
you get these people you don't know what
they're due
what they're thinking where they are and
then they just bargue you with any
thought that runs through their head
it's just such a weird thing when you do
get validation from it like Oh
7,000 people think I'm really funny yeah
and as I mean you're funny like it's a
weird world that we get at the end of
the day you have to so that's why I was
respecting what was going on with the
last guy of the same like finding
himself working on himself he doesn't
like I was being defined by this because
I mean I respect them I'm not quitting
I'm not sick around okay yeah yeah
anyway subscribe to the real rejects
subscribe to top unknown
fall capital urban on social media I'm
on there once a day and once a day I
don't ever like it later on and I want
you to see come up paying attention to
do you know right yeah I want you go
crazy why is it great I mean why are you
watching my entry Ansari my life is
these days download your idea what the
hell are you going to do so I just like
you know when you don't take a video
when you're out and I'd really got
someone else is filming it all just
still there and then you can't dam is
over